Keep this about a fist away and we're
live.
Douglas,
first of all,
thanks for joining me.
Appreciate it.
Great presence to be with you.
Looking forward to talking to you like
you've become an example to me or your
conversation with Sam Harris.
Become an example to me of how squirly
things have gotten lately with the way
people interpret conversations about
ideas because of this.
Jamie,
pull that thing up.
This is a tweet that someone sent out
and he got a strike,
a community guideline strike just for
listening just for putting you on his
playlist,
a conversation between Sam Harris and
you.
And uh,
he.
This man,
um,
or I don't know if it's a man.
I'm,
I just assumed I'm,
I'm a problem.
I'm part of the problem.
Part of the Patriarchy pet are Kaye cee,
cee x on twitter.
That is his screen name or his or her or
Azura screen name on twitter and got a
community guideline strike for just
putting this.
Now I brought this up too.
I was having dinner with some friends.
One of them who used to work at Google
and someone who's there was a highly
ranked person.
Okay,
Youtube.
I brought this up and the exact quote
was,
uh,
that was because it's hate speech.
And I said,
you said that so flippantly.
I go,
please tell me the contents of the
conversation.
Do you know what they talked about?
I go,
how did you say that she was white?
I'm sure if someone marked it as a
community guideline,
strike a community strike.
What is it called?
The community guidelines that they must
be hate speech.
I'm like,
do you understand?
This is Douglas Murray and Sam Harris.
I,
I bet.
I bet that's not what the conversation
was about.
I bet it wasn't too.
I'm trying to think of what we did.
Talk about it now.
It's making me nervous.
I mean,
but I know that.
I know.
It definitely wasn't hate speech by any
saying definition of those words that
you,
this sort of thing is very disturbing.
Very disturbing.
You and you noticed that happening with
other people and that's disturbing
enough is more disturbing.
Of course it happens to you,
but it's real.
I mean,
I know Sam Harris a bit,
not a hateful person,
my most sorta yoga calm,
blissed out west coast of America
friend,
and I'm pretty amazed that anyone at
Google or anyone else would think that
anything that could come out of his
mouth with hate speech,
hate speech,
unless you decided that hate speech is
just anything you'd personally don't
like or the words don't matter anymore.
Well,
that's what I'm concerned about.
I'm concerned that
there is an agenda that people who work
in these.
We don't even have to name the
organizations,
but in certain organizations are
left leaning and I mean it's probably
better than being extremely
right-leaning,
so it really is.
It's probably better than them being
white supremacists,
white nationalists hate groups probably
far better that they're radical lefties,
but it becomes a problem when you're
doing things like that because things
like that limit free speech and they
limit the free discussion of ideas.
I don't.
I didn't listen to your conversation.
I think I listened to a little bit of
it,
but I didn't listen to enough of it to
know whether or not you guys started
screaming at the end word halfway in.
I'm sure I'd remember.
I'm sure.
I'm sure you would have this moment.
I had another thing that I talked about
with this same person.
I brought up Jordan Peterson and you
know that there's.
There's issues with every time he's on
podcast,
the podcast get flagged for
demonetization and the exact words were,
he's a troublemaker and I'm like,
what in the fuck are you talking about?
Like are you listening to his
conversations?
He is very articulate and he's extremely
careful going over these ideas that I
think we should all be discussing,
so to call this hate speech or to call
someone a troublemaker.
It to me,
it's simple.
Simplify or symbolizes what we're.
What we're dealing with today.
This is a very strange time when it
comes to communication and the people
that regulate and distributed
communication.
It is whenever I've had a chance to
speak with people in that kind of world
and that sort of role.
The question I always want to ask him on
other things is,
do you know where this is going to lead?
Do you know what it's going to do if you
keep breaking down definitions and terms
and words,
do you know what happens?
For instance,
down the road,
if,
if you keep on saying that Sam Harris
and Doris Martin having a conversation
about something is hate speech.
Do you know what relief that's going to
give other people down the road about
what they're going to be able to get
away with?
This is what's being created all the
time.
In the moment.
It seems to me there's this idea that
you,
you police the discussion along
incredibly narrow lines that happened to
surround your own comfort zone and call
everything outside.
It's not just stuff I don't agree with
or things that I would argue with or
debate with hate speech.
Uh,
it's just,
I think very,
very dangerous down the road you can see
exactly the trail that bit of gunpowder
goes to.
I can.
Where do you think it goes?
I think it goes to the point where
people become cynical about any,
any claims made about anyone and the
likelihood is that if 99 times you've
seen Sam Harris started with Mary Joe
Rogan,
Jordan Peterson,
whoever called hate speech,
then the hundredth time that somebody
uses the term hate speech might be on
somebody who is engaging in hate speech
and all your defenses are going to be
down.
You've got nothing.
You're very likely to become a very
unlikely.
Sorry to become skeptical.
Um,
and think I'm really gonna dig that.
Most of us don't have time.
We didn't have time to find out every
single thought and words someone has
uttered or thought.
And so it seems very likely to me that
down the road very,
very bad people were able to get through
the gates because we kept on making
erroneous claims frivolously for our own
short term gain and fro in short term
comfort.
And we'll end up basically bringing the
gates down completely.
I agree with you and I,
I think there's been a lot of discussion
lately as well that I agree with where
when you make these ridiculous claims
about conversations,
you,
you empower,
you actually empower radical people
posed left wing ideology.
Yeah.
They get more extreme.
You empower the extremists because they
know that you're incorrect.
They have evidence of it.
They see your ridiculous behavior and
the other really disturbing aspect of it
as these are the people that are
distributing speech,
right?
I mean think about how many discussions
are viewed daily on Youtube.
It's stunning
the,
there,
um,
there's so much.
I mean,
we're at the beginning of this.
I don't wait because I mean there's a
long way for this to run a long way for
the censorship to run the long.
You can't help thinking among other
things that the people trying to make
the rules at the moment have no idea of
the fact that these debates have
happened before.
Well,
have not bothered to look into them and
seem to think that history started with
them.
And I just wish that among other things
with social media,
people realized w we have been through
this several times before at least,
and the lessons are pretty clear,
are not that you can limit speech in
order to obtain political nirvana,
for instance,
a.
nor are they,
that you can simply use,
I say,
for short term gain accusations,
you know,
to be wrong.
Right?
In order to further a short term
political goal,
uh,
we know all this.
We've been through a printing press.
We went through with John Stuart Mill.
We went through it with Milton.
I just wish these people had any idea of
the fact that history started before the
parents can see them.
Well,
it's such that the whole culture of tech
today is such a progressive thought
bubble.
It's,
it's an echo chamber and it's very,
very hard.
I,
like I said,
it's better that they're really
progressive and open minded and left
Wayne and radical right wing.
I think it's better.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
I mean,
if by radical right wing you mean.
Yeah,
of course.
Although these people have all,
as I say,
all the ability to create those people,
right?
Um,
which is power it empower them,
which is something you don't want actual
racists and Nazis to have legitimate
grievance claims and you don't want them
to be able to disguise themselves as
something they're not.
So I say I had a friend who,
um,
a lot of friends involved in the
Northern Ireland conflict in many years
ago in the UK and all that many years
ago,
one writer had a beautiful phrase about
w w where you've got the stage wherever
I was killing everyone.
He said you also got to the stage where
truth was whatever you were having
yourself.
And um,
we're not far away from that.
That place where I say what you call is
hate speech.
You see what I say is hate speech.
Let's call the whole thing off.
We're not very far away from that
actually.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
it's very strange that this,
this echo chamber is being so reinforced
and that very few people are stepping
out and saying,
well,
wait,
let's take a look at this.
Subjectively know the people that do do
that are signaled out as being racist or
sexist or homophobic or transphobic or
what,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Whatever is convenient.
Yeah.
And it,
but it's not surprising that more people
don't want to stick their heads up.
That's perfect because I mean,
if you had a normal job,
uh,
you worked in a normal office or sharp
or something,
you,
you really don't want this coming
towards you,
right?
Um,
I,
I mean this,
this can tear apart and tear down people
who spend a lifetime demonstrating they
are not the thing that they're being
accused of.
So if nobody knows anything about you,
you have no particular persona out
there,
you have no particular back record.
You don't want this and coming to tell
your life down,
right?
Because recovering from that accusation
is almost impossible and will take you
wherever it is basically impossible.
And all that you do along the way is to
keep reminding people of the charge.
And if you were to ever win on a
technicality,
like everyone would have forgotten the,
Oh yeah,
that's the,
uh,
that's the racist.
That's the rapist.
I mean he was pro rape,
isn't remember him.
Yeah,
it's so simple,
but it's.
I feel like we're in some strange
adolescent stage of communication and
there's been a bunch of talk lately.
There's.
There were some something that I tweeted
earlier today,
some new technology that they believe
were ai is going to allow people to
literally see other people's thoughts.
Right and I am forever optimistic but
also terrified and my feeling is that
our transition from language,
here it is,
new ai system can see what you are
thinking,
which is just what the hell does that
mean?
I'm I'm concern,
but also optimistic.
I feel like we're in this transitionary
period from regular communication to
written communication,
to written communication on line
two,
speech online,
video online where there's this instant
access to all this and these ideas are
being debated and tossed around like
beach balls in real time and ideas are
being distorted.
People's positions are being distorted
for for other people's gains and that
there is this willful misuse of the
truth and that something is going to
come along that's going to combat that,
but at what price?
I mean the.
I can't see what would come along to do
it other than people rebelling against
it.
Their own free will as it was.
It doesn't seem like that's happening
though.
It seems like there's a few people that
are rec like yourself and there's many
others that are recognizing the problem
with this.
There's people talking about the problem
of it online,
but for the most part the mass of people
are engaged in this and it's also it's
idea sport.
There's idea sport going on where their
side,
they want their side to score.
Sure,
sure.
Well,
that's always old politics and your
country at any rate at the moment is how
can we make sure that the other side
trips up on this,
and I've felt this,
I've written this all through the me,
an era that in your country and their
mind,
people are basically are willing to go
for somebody who is a political opponent
who does something very minimal and
they're willing to defend somebody on
the inside who does something bigger and
you can see it all the time.
It just.
There are different standards that apply
to your own side then apply to the other
and people don't seem to be hiding it
very much anymore.
Not at all and they really don't have
the ability to hide it.
No.
We had a case recently in the UK where
somebody who was a great heritage of the
left full sorts of complicated reasons
was accused of some fairly.
I'm very serious,
groping accusations about how this and
exactly the left wing MPs who had been
claiming that somebody who had sent out
a tweet about a woman's breasts in 2009
should never hold any role in public,
said that this person who just happened
to be a friend and an icon of theirs was
a changed man and we have to recognize
this.
Eighteen months ago now,
and my favorite video on this was a.
There was a guy who is a some rigid
religious Christian man on television
and he was talking about trump and he
was talking about who trump was before
he became president.
He goes,
but I don't know about you,
but I've found Jesus and I did not have
a past put praise Jesus and he's saying
this and everyone's cheering.
He,
whoever he was before he found Jesus
side as if trump got into office.
It was like,
you know what?
I'm a new man.
I found Jesus.
I got the Jesus passed all that stuff
that I did the last 70 years.
Well,
some people,
some people do treat that as a
journalist.
Malcolm muggeridge very distinguished
figure in the media,
um,
some years ago,
but
who it was often noted that his,
he converted to Catholicism and he,
uh,
a mutual friend once said that it was
noticeable.
Malcolm muggeridge always attacked
advice immediately after he had become
incapable of it himself when it was
clear the mortgage didn't have as much
sex as he did fairly often in his youth.
Sex was a big problem.
It's a giant problem.
He needs to let everybody know.
Yeah,
virtue signaling to the highest degree.
Let everybody know this is awful.
All that pleasure and flesh stop it.
I wouldn't have it.
I had a lot of it,
but I won't have it anymore.
Not In my bedroom.
It's just,
I don't know,
man.
I'm just,
I'm hopeful.
I'm hopeful that we're gonna work
through this.
But um,
I'm also disturbed because no one's at
the wheel.
There's,
there's no particular logical human
being that's out at the wheel that has a
real rational sort of a solution for all
of these issues.
It's just chaos.
And in funding,
the
problem is,
again,
it comes back to thinking about the
truth being whatever you're having
yourself.
We don't have any one that we might
mutually agree on some kind of empire.
I mean,
that's,
that's becoming,
that's becoming part of the problem.
Who,
who,
who.
I mean,
I'd be very suspicious of any empire put
forward,
but,
but where would you roughly look for
one?
I'm a,
I like to think that truth is still
massive,
but you know,
when you discover that a lot of people
don't seem to particularly care for it
or willing to sacrifice it,
as I say for some other purpose,
including winning a goal.
Um,
it's hard to see how you could
adjudicate in this era,
but just one of the photos in it,
which is a lot of this has to do with
whether or not the online world can
forgive.
This seems to me to be a really central
thing.
One of the,
one of the things that came up the case
I said recently about this 2009 cases,
somebody in Britain who tweeted about a
woman's breasts,
among other things was he mistook
twitter for a conversation with friends.
And how did he do that?
You know,
I mean,
he's in public office and a journalist
and a,
but was,
was going to get a public office anyhow,
but the point is,
is that,
uh,
you know,
we don't really know what the rules are
that are.
I mean like what if you were a bit of a
Dick 10 years ago like that on a medium
that people were still finding their way
on and now you are genuinely,
you moved on kids and,
and yet the,
the breast tweet is always with you.
I mean,
it's a sort of dystopian nightmare that
you'd always be stuck with your worst
joke.
You'd be stuck with your lowest sort of
crisis moment recently with Bill Maher,
right?
Bill Maher,
there was something that he wrote,
I think in 1989.
Right?
Which is insane.
I mean,
29 years ago he wrote something and uh,
people used it recently against him in
29.
I don't know how old billy is,
I don't think bill is even 60,
so we're talking about something that he
wrote when he was in his twenties and he
was a struggling standup comedian.
The,
uh,
the,
the is very good for this,
isn't it?
Because you can,
you can,
you can dig up everyone.
Everyone's made.
Everyone is.
Everyone's screwed up from you,
you know,
apart from yourself.
It's a w.
We had somebody recently in Burton who,
who ever wanted to go for suddenly and
they found an article he had written
about saying he didn't agree with
Holocaust denial laws.
Okay.
He said,
he said,
he said he just thought it was a bad
idea for free speech,
you know,
uh,
when the,
when the Internet was a second story to
find out other stuff about it and they
found an article which said,
I'm a Holocaust denier,
so,
you know,
prosecute me sorta thing,
which he isn't a Holocaust denier.
It's just nobody bothered to read
beneath the headline and say suddenly in
the middle of the thing,
wherever I was telling about his life,
they also said Andy's a Holocaust
denier,
and that was,
that was that.
And unlike something he wrote 15 years
ago and it wasn't even an event,
it's a headline or something.
Uh,
and yeah,
and everyone.
And again,
nobody cares.
Get onto the next victim.
Uh,
everyone's a Nazi.
It's almost like people,
I mean,
it's obviously the case of living
glasshouses and throwing tons of rocks,
but it's almost like everyone is just
trying to throw as many rocks as they
can before rock start coming their way
because they know it's inevitable.
Well,
I thought I felt until February the
object of life in the modern era was to
prove everyone else was a racist Nazi,
misogynistic,
transphobic.
And then you win is somehow coronation
or something.
Everyone would say,
oh,
you're the person who's good,
but now,
yes.
It seems everyone is aware that it's,
it's,
it's a Mexican gunfight.
Yeah.
I have a friend of mine who had been on
this podcast before,
back when he was a radical lefties,
name's Jamie Kilstein,
and he's a stand up comedian and he was
a real radical social justice warrior,
male feminists,
lefty,
and they turned on him radical.
What did they do horribly at?
Well,
they found out he was trying to have sex
with girls.
That can be another one and it was all.
It was just having sex.
That was it.
He,
he,
he didn't rape anybody who didn't grow
up.
Anybody.
He just,
he threw some passes and less passes are
100 percent successful?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
The same exact paths could be your
future wife.
Right.
And this one just felt 15 yards short.
There's no room for error,
but he,
he took long time off of social media in
a long time off of performing and these.
He came on and was really brave about it
and he talked about who we used to be
and he said he was in this frantic state
where he was just constantly attacking
people,
just attacking people and then checking
his twitter or see who responded to that
attack and where people are on his side,
you know,
are people agreeing with him as he
getting those social justice points that
he wanted and he was really honest about
the feeling that he got the Ang anxiety
that I think a lot of people engage in
on a daily basis.
A lot of.
If you go to people,
there's quite a few people that I follow
that seem to just always be in conflict
and I just go to watch.
I'll just go to their page almost like
I'm watching a fistfight in the backyard
and they're just.
It seems like there's this.
They're addicted to this constant seesaw
of emotions and this interaction.
It is.
It releases the necessarily chemical in
the brain.
They get,
they get upset when they step away from
it for a bit.
I don't engage in any of that,
that bit of it because I've seen
suddenly a lot of the most mediocre
minds of my generation brought low by
this.
I mean there are some people who I
admired until I followed them on social
media and,
and now I just think,
you know,
your,
the shouty angry person who's,
who's,
who's like a drunk at closing time,
desperate,
flailing around with your fists are
looking for somebody to fight with them.
And,
and to what end,
you know,
the other,
another experience I had,
I've had in recent years that led me to
not want to engage in this is walking
around in various events in sort of
breakout things.
You people who,
you know,
really people I've admired in the past
all saying things like,
you see that,
you see I flame decks on twitter.
I do see what I tweeted about that
person.
I think these used to be serious people
in these used to be serious.
People engaged in serious things and
here they are engaged in these for
flailing fistfights and often,
often let's face it on things.
Which if you didn't do it like that,
seeking out the fight or the sort of
thing that would allow for normal human
interaction.
I mean,
how many disagreements do we have with
people in our personal lives all the
time?
If we wanted to write,
you didn't vote this way,
that way.
I mean some people would mind about
that,
but you know,
I know you've,
you think slightly differently for me on
this particular issue,
you don't say let's have that out now
once and for all you,
um,
you,
you find ways to live with people's
differences and different opinions and
you're not going to get everyone exactly
in line.
I mean,
we all knew that before the age of
social media and now it seems to be the
only aim.
What do you think that is?
I mean,
think it's what we were discussing
earlier,
that it's idea of sport and then you
just get caught up in like someone
volleyed your way and so you have to
smash that tennis ball back their way.
It is something like that.
I mean,
I,
I can't say I haven't felt the vicarious
pleasure of some of that myself.
You know,
that old Chinese proverb about I'm
sitting by the river watching the bodies
of your enemies float by.
I had a big sense of that the other day
when somebody I deeply disliked came
across her on social media at the same
time as somebody else I deeply disliked
was being held by the French police on
serious charges.
And I thought that was,
I felt like the Chinese proverb.
That's all right.
And so I can,
I can see why people feel it.
Sure.
And of course people who they could
never normally get to who they've got
to.
I mean,
I think that's,
I think that's the big,
uh,
the big thing of,
you know,
look,
I poked that.
You know what?
I never engaged on social media for
precisely that reason,
that reason among others that you would
never,
I would never want somebody to know that
they could get to me.
Even if they,
even if you just block them,
there's many people who take pride.
Even in their heading.
They say,
I am blocked on twitter by all these
people and,
and actually I do sometimes read what
people say is sending to me.
Um,
and I've never blocked anyone because I
sort of thing you should mind that if
you put your ideas out there,
you might as well be as open as possible
to receiving them back some time ago
when I got into a car with the,
with the Turkish president about,
uh,
about something,
I got all these Turkish,
uh,
sort of accounts sending me stuff.
There's one guy,
he just repeatedly sent me a pornography
of animals having sex with.
So I didn't know it is,
it's very,
it was very hardcore.
And um,
and so I used to go down the feet.
Now that gun I didn't even block in
actually because I sort of thought,
well,
somewhere in Turkey,
he's a really angry man,
desperately finding horse pornography
send to me.
And in a way I felt so sorry for him
that that was how his life had come up
with the end.
His life had come to at this stage that
I,
I couldn't even block him.
And also he'd be like,
I'm the donkey porn guy who got blocked
by dark.
He'd get a certain thing.
What was his motivation for sending you
this stuff?
He,
I,
um,
it was because,
well,
the short story is a couple of years ago
with the Turkey's president tried to get
the German chancellor to imprison a
German comic for a very rude poem he'd
read on air on German television that
was insulting about the Turkish
president.
And the German authorities actually
started a case against the comedian for
insulting the Turkish president,
Edwin.
And uh,
I,
uh,
decided to launch a,
a,
an offensive poetry competition to
offend the Turkish president.
And there was a thousand pounds cash
prize and it sort of took off.
And in the end,
the now foreign secretary entered in
one.
Yes.
That's great.
Yes,
it was really good because at the same
time that the Germans were looking at
imprisoning a comedian,
uh,
the,
the now foreign secretary,
the UK was guilty of precisely the same
alleged crime.
I eman,
it wasn't a crime,
it couldn't be a crime.
A couple other people did.
Wonderful Dutch comedian friend,
Hans Johnson,
or sort of a similar thing that time he
decided to do an interview live on Dutch
television,
explaining how much he hated him because
he still owed him money from the
blowjob.
He'd given Edwin in a sauna and the
Dutch authorities were looking at.
Actually we're looking at.
They were asked if they would prosecute
him,
but anyhow,
but this was,
this was,
I had a great time with this of course,
and I wrote a limerick explaining how
I'm abusive.
I wanted people to be about Edwin,
that it wasn't necessary to be highly
defamatory and you wouldn't get away
with it if you just called him a banker
or something.
So I wrote the opening verse and invited
the world to contribute,
which they did and it became,
among other things,
the highest paid poetry competition in
the world.
If,
if like me,
you read a Limerick,
just five lines,
200 pounds a light.
And I mean,
no,
no.
A poetry,
a magazine could pave for such a,
uh,
such such work.
So anyhow,
on the basis of that,
I became very,
very unpopular in Turkey.
And there were many,
many pieces talking about how this gay
atheist,
terrible Edwin Hater in Britain was
exactly what we're up against.
So him and his poems.
Oh my God.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the German government was actually
considering.
Yes.
Prosecuting this guy.
How far did they take it?
Uh,
he was taken in for questioning.
I know he had to retain lawyers.
I'm fairly sure they did only drop it in
the end because of the international
attention that was paid to it.
There was this easy,
there was this law on the books.
It's still set.
It was less imagine stay Lord about
defending foreign rulers.
And he had,
he had done it for such an important
reason as well,
which was to say,
you know,
we in Germany should have the right to
be rude about Edward,
particularly Edwin,
who you know,
was promoted for Matt to Prime Minister.
Now the president wants to be so tired,
you know,
I mean,
it is a very bad man.
Locked up more journalists per capita,
I think,
than any other country in the world
other than China,
which I don't think we can get the stats
on a very,
very evil.
I think man who,
who has led his country backwards in the
last 20 years and this is in the process
of trying to destroy a wonderful country
and if you can't be rude about him,
if you can't pretend that he sleeps with
animals,
um,
which is what the German comedian
started with,
then somewhere down the line you might
be able to say anything about the
imprisoned journalists either and so on.
And,
um,
since also by the way,
people don't seem to spend my time
worrying about the Turkish journalist
Edwin in prisons.
I'm the least.
They paid attention when I said that.
Uh,
he and Angela Merkel got up to really
filthy filthy acts in the zoo.
Well,
obviously the worst case of retaliation
for humor.
It's probably Charlie Updo,
right?
I mean,
which is a terrible.
And unfortunately many people weren't
defending the murder,
but we're talking the murderers.
I mean,
I think how many.
I think it was 11 people were murdered
and ended up placing a police officer,
um,
they,
but they were saying that instead of
concentrating on the murder,
which was done completely out of this,
reinforcing their rules of their
ideology and in retaliation for any
mocking of that ideology,
instead of that,
they were talking about how racist
Charlie Hebdo was.
There was a lot of that.
In fact,
my friend Jamie Kilstein was a part of
that.
He was on television back in his super
social justice warrior days.
Talking about that you wish you might
have other things that people said,
no,
I'm not talking about something if they
don't know about it.
Yeah.
In my guess was that until,
until the murders,
I mean an infinitely small number of
people knew about Shaadi Abdo outside of
France.
I found myself in the wake of that in
studios with people who I know how to
just googled Charlene's up there the day
before.
I know that they just gone to wikipedia
and read an English version of a claim
about what that magazine was about.
Goes back to my point about the
journalist in the Holocaust denial thing
that you just root around a bunch of
people being killed.
This doesn't seem to vindicate my sides
ideology.
Therefore,
let me find what I can do to defame them
and.
Oh good.
Somebody.
Charlene Abdo once did this cartoon that
was off color and I can't understand
what the words are beneath it,
but I'll,
I'll claim it's racist to me.
People were actually doing that.
They're actually,
there were,
there was a,
um,
there was one cartoon that was used
against Charlie Hebdo after the
massacre.
Uh,
that was a joke against the front
nasional and the claims they were making
about the black woman in Sarcozi
government.
But because the joke and the rich,
if you didn't speak French,
it wasn't clear.
It apparently,
but it.
And if you knew nothing about recent
French history,
you knew nothing about the social,
the Sarcozi administration and,
and the,
and the ministry in question.
These people just went to it and said
racist cartoon.
Not Noticing that the cartoon was
actually a joke about racists,
but they didn't.
They didn't bother to find that out.
And I thought that I thought that whole
thing among many,
many other things was deeply worrying
from that point of view because it means
that in the immediate aftermath of
something that should be so damn clear,
a bunch of people can just try to
reframe the narrative.
Yeah.
And really change the history of a
publication.
Yeah.
Um,
claim it is just something different.
And,
and for a lot of people,
of course that was very,
um,
that was very convenient because after
all,
if Charlie,
his staff actually were these racists,
then you know,
you didn't need to worry too much about
them or why you'd been silent on the
issues they've spoken up about.
Yeah.
The narrative then been that these
people had been mocking this
disenfranchised marginalized group in
society and that they had it coming in
some very strange way.
And it's part of me struggled with that
because I was like,
is this,
some people just have contrarion
instincts.
Everybody's going left.
They just go,
I don't like it.
And they want to go the other way.
There's so many people that have that
instinct.
And then there's,
as you said before,
this headline mentality,
they read the headline and don't look
any further into it.
Even if it's a headline about a
headline,
it's theirs.
That's all they need.
They're armed with enough facts.
They slam their laptop down and start
debating.
Yeah.
And in that case,
as in many others,
totally lose sight of the only thing
that matters.
The only thing that matters in that case
being,
is it ever right to make apologies for
people walking into an office and
gunning down people for an opinion.
You don't like the honest,
which has to be,
of course no.
Has to be,
has to be now.
And yet in these moments.
So we had 1:20
years before with the rush,
dfs,
the satanic verses.
If in these moments you discover that
you don't have the allies on your side,
you thought you did in the wake of the
rush,
tfl and 89,
it was people from the right and the
left in Britain who started making
excuses for the ayatollah in,
uh,
we had,
the,
the chief rabbi of the UK Djokovics to
his,
to his shame,
said both Mr Rusty and vio taller has
offended people's feelings as if someone
had in,
in,
you know,
called on all novelists to go to Tehran,
assassinate the ayatollah if they had a
chance.
You had a,
um,
somebody like a right wing conservative
minister,
uh,
Jeffery Howe who said that said that
overall she had done,
had really offended Britain.
He'd been rude about Britain as if that
had anything to do with anything.
Um,
there was uh,
one,
um,
there was one famous case of a,
of a conservative peer who said about
Rushdie that he wouldn't bother him if a
group of young Muslims took Mr Roche
into an alleyway and taught him some
manners.
And so,
and you had that from the left as well.
Bernie,
granted,
Labour MP famously said at that point
the burning books wasn't a problem for
him.
Um,
and uh,
that was when they were burning the
satanic verses in Bradford,
so,
so you get these weird coalitions of
people who suddenly turned out not to
get the point,
not to get the point,
not want to defend,
and then of course you get the cowards
to say things like,
well,
it wasn't my sort of novel,
you know,
I,
I didn't think novel was all that good.
I midnight's children,
I could cope with static versus he lost
me with a plot as if that means that
then you can call for the death of the
author rather than just give it a bad
review.
How is he now?
Salman Rushdie still in hiding.
I know he does a lot of interviews now
and it seems to be more relaxed.
Yes.
He seems to be,
I don't know the specifics.
He,
um,
there was an assurance,
I think given some years ago in the
labor year Labor government,
the width Tehran,
that they would not actively,
uh,
um,
encourage the murder of rushed anymore.
Um,
how nice.
Nice icer them,
that's a freezing and unfreezing
relations,
uh,
but,
but the point I wanted to make was it,
that's again,
we've all,
we've been through these things.
We know how it plays out with the
Charlie Hebdo,
uh,
events,
the murder of the staff and contributors
to that magazine.
We knew in the immediate aftermath what
was going on and that,
that there were people who just wanted
to make excuses and you still hear that
everywhere.
I mean,
I,
I've heard it on every single free
speech debate in my adult life.
Um,
I remember growing up and I remember in
every one of the things in recent years
from the Danish cartoons to the Julia
Medina scandal,
a publisher London's firebombed for
publishing a novel.
It was actually amazingly phoning about
Mohammed,
uh,
to charlene abdomen since you,
you just get these,
this strange group of people from
brightened left some believers and
nonbelievers who always just come up
with these bullshit bullshit arguments
and say things like,
well,
I didn't find the cartoon very funny.
Or,
or I never,
I never took that magazine seriously
awhile.
I didn't think it was right when they
did this and it just,
they just don't,
for some reason have the fortitude to
just say the only thing that matters in
the wake of that,
which is no.
Do you think that's because Islam is
unique in their approach to anything
that goes outside the lines of what they
feel is.
Oh,
absolutely acceptable in terms of like
they will murder you if you draw
Muhammad.
Yeah.
This is,
this is,
this is what's been described as the
internalization of the fat.
Um,
if,
uh,
I'm sure you've had this experience,
but it's actually worse now,
the presumption is worse than the actual
reality.
I have quite often people say to me now,
I'd like to write this piece about Hex,
but I don't know if I can because you
know,
it might get a death sentence.
And actually I always say,
what are you talking about?
Right.
It fortunately,
so far I haven't given that advice in
the person's him being in any way under
any actual danger lambien killed.
Right?
But,
and I think I might feel differently if
that was the case.
Um,
but,
uh,
but that,
but there is this,
an overcompensation occurring at the
moment and it goes far,
far within the,
within the boundaries of what actually
could plausibly get you into any trouble
whether or not the trouble is,
you know,
legitimate to get into or not.
Um,
so that now,
yeah,
I've had many journalists in recent
years,
particularly since shiny objects will
sidle up to me and say,
well,
I'd quite like to do this for,
I don't,
I don't dare.
And,
and you know,
I mean I'm talking about for like very
basic reporting and things that they're
not people saying,
hey,
I decided to draw a great big cartoon of
Mohammed with a great big dick.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
having sex with the pope or something.
You know,
it's not that,
it's never that.
It's never people saying,
I'm really just so keen to draw Mohammed
today.
Douglas,
what did I do?
It never is that.
It's always something way,
way,
way down.
I'm thinking of even like saying
something critical if sense and regimes.
So,
so the internalization of the fat ones
since 1989,
which has been exacerbated now by the
killings,
the Charlie Hebdo and as well the
attacks on the unit as Boston in Denmark
means that we are in this period where,
where people are really hyper
hypersensitive and they really shouldn't
be because it really isn't that bad.
It's not as bad as they think.
But this is,
you know,
you can do so much work if you,
if you say to people,
I've got Kalashnikovs on my side,
I mean the extent and people in free
societies.
I got really,
really loathe to admit this,
but it's the classic is a classic sort
of a mob trek,
you know,
knocking on someone's door.
I'm very disappointed in you,
but my friend,
my huge friend,
uh,
is a,
is a really angry and I'm just holding
him back.
You can do an amazing amount of work if
you're willing to pull that trick.
And if you can persuade people and it's
actually the case that there are people
you're holding back,
that you can make enormous inroads like
that.
Well,
especially when there's actual evidence
that people have been murdered and
happened.
Absolutely.
One of the more fascinating things about
Charlie Hebdo to me was the refusal of
any of the mainstream media to show any
of the cartoons.
Yes.
You had to go online and I felt like
this was a.
They gave up the reins of information to
the Internet when it was,
was a real transitionary moment in our
culture.
Yes.
Everyone went online to see what.
Yeah,
the only place to go pump from your
parents,
you know,
they were still under the impression
that these must be incredibly
pornographic cartoons that were really
viciously attacking
somebody.
But no,
most anyone young can.
I could find this out for themselves.
And you're right,
they,
they gave up the,
uh,
the space to the net and they all,
they all had,
again,
these sort of rubbishy I arguments that
their own about it.
I tried in Britain to,
uh,
get the press to do it at one go and a
couple of days after the massacre and,
um,
got pretty close,
uh,
that if everyone's there.
So I am spartacus tactic.
If everyone did it at once,
then it'll be okay,
but it would make it easier and the
argument you always get about that is,
and is a very persuasive argument,
is that the editor of the magazine or
newspaper might get protection.
So,
but you know,
a girl from the typing pool sort of
thing and the,
which is what happened actually in some
of the satanic verses,
killings,
stabbings and things like the Norwegian
translate with Japanese translator,
you know,
it's people who under no security
protocol could possibly end up or
getting protected.
Uh,
and,
and on the basis of fearing that the
boss who almost always says no,
one of the more uniquely American
responses to the Charlie Hebdo attack
was they had a drama Mohammed contest in
Texas.
Yes,
I followed that.
Yeah.
That was fascinating.
And some guy showed up and started
shooting at the building and they were
killed almost immediately.
Yes.
Which is because they're in Texas and
that's just not the place to fuck
around.
Although,
I mean,
it's worth mentioning with,
I mean the,
the,
the editor at Charlie Hebdo had police
protection in Paris and they just,
I mean,
I suppose they were not worth dwelling
or better than the,
they,
uh,
the,
the battle trained people who were sent
from Yemen to carry out that operation.
We just were better prepared than the
French authorities realized.
Um,
very few people are really ready to
militarize cartoonist offices.
And that's really almost what you would
have to do.
You would have to have navy seals of
bulletproof vests.
Yes.
And then packed and loaded.
And then let's face it,
I mean,
the whole thing.
Then you do start to question,
you know,
like,
well,
is this cartoon that funny?
So.
Yeah.
And that's what they actually have done
it.
You have,
they have,
they did a little while ago,
say,
look,
we're not gonna keep doing this.
Well,
didn't they have
Mohammed making out with someone like,
almost
immediately after.
That's right.
Yeah.
But after about a year or so,
they,
the,
they stopped.
They said they didn't want to do
Mohammed again.
And,
uh,
and uh,
and you can't blame them.
I mean,
this is the thing,
isn't that a,
I'm sure you have this experience in
these sorts of time.
I,
I always get people on the,
apart from the Turkish donkey porn guy,
other people on twitter send me things
like,
you know,
well,
why don't you draw Mohammed sort of
stuff.
Sure.
And first of all,
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm not a cartoonist,
but secondly,
the way in which this is always
presented is amazing because it's always
fun.
Like Xena,
Warrior,
Princess Twelve,
93,
you don't have the guts to draw Mohammed
Mary and you know,
like,
well you don't even know the guts of
your own name on twitter mate.
So,
uh,
but,
but there's,
there's a bit of,
of egging along.
What happens in those cases?
I don't want to draw Mohammed,
I don't want to Piss people off by
drawing the cartoon.
But what I do want to point out is that
you,
if you,
if you don't defend people's rights to
draw things without getting murdered.
Yes.
And you're living in an insane society.
Yeah.
And,
and the,
there's another thing we said,
we all know what comes next.
I mean,
my point about this has always been
think of something smaller than a
cartoon to do,
right?
I mean,
I still reserve the right to be amazed.
We call something a cartoon crisis and
keep a straight face.
You know,
we're going to have to militarize in
Garland,
Texas because there's a cartoon crisis.
Well known
natural progression could easily be
your.
You're not allowed to draw the cartoon.
Then from there you're not allowed to
speak of drawing.
And then from there you have to show
that you have a very certain idea in
your head of what is good and one is
bad.
So you have to show that by verbalizing
something.
So you're forced to forced to verbalize
And let's face it,
it's not as if it's just the cartoon.
That's the problem is it?
I mean,
it's a novel,
it's short,
so on and so forth.
Sandy phone.
And that's one of my big beefs about
this is that a,
I don't want to not say what I think is
true and even if that does offend,
you know,
one point three or 4 billion people,
it is often said and tones that are not
entirely unthreatening.
Uh,
if,
uh,
Charlie Hebdo or somebody else can't
draw a cartoon of Muhammad and then I
know that exactly in tandem with that is
somebody saying,
and you douglas or you,
Joe,
you,
anyone else can say what you find in the
texts or what you think about this
religion and you can join the rest of,
uh,
of the society and being brave and going
to the book of Mormon on a Friday night
for a laugh is a laugh.
But don't you dare think of applying to
Islam the same kind of speech you would
apply to mormonism.
And that,
that I,
that I won't do,
I just,
I just weren't joining in on that.
And um,
despite there being a price to pay for
that,
but I just wouldn't not say what I think
is true in these matters.
Are you aware of what they did with
South Park?
With South Park South Park?
It got very crazy were they not only
could not draw Muhammad,
they couldn't draw Muhammad in a bear
suit,
so then they have Mohammed in a bear
suit in an armored car,
so you couldn't even see him,
but it was implied that Muhammad was
inside the armored car in a bear suit
and it's still.
But they did my homies voice,
didn't they?
Yeah,
they.
They gave him a screwy voice.
Great Voice.
So that was a kid.
As long as you joke about the voice of
Muhammad,
you okay,
but don't you dare show him.
It's fucking insane.
It's really weird as well because again,
they all make presumptions.
It's just not true.
It's not true that nobody ever drew
Mohammed.
It's not true.
There are illustrations in books that
are still on sale of very old
illustrations Mohammed through
throughout Islamic history.
That's before they knew better,
bro.
Didn't know better,
but got a new note from Mohammed.
Mohammed is like,
look,
I don't like these fucking drawings.
Me and not about killing people.
They don't show my best side,
and this is,
this is,
this is a very strange position to be in
because South Park ends up holding the
line.
Then south park,
it's like fat tire against South Bucket.
What?
I didn't see that headline coming.
Um,
and again,
everyone internalizes it and everyone
thinks,
well,
you know,
I,
I admire them in the Mormon work,
but I wouldn't follow them.
And then Mohammed works.
So,
and then the whole culture tilts it.
Um,
and that's,
that's I think where we are at the
moment on this.
And I,
uh,
I just,
you know,
the cartoon will never be funny enough.
The joke will never be funny enough.
A novel will never be good enough and so
on.
And,
and then in the end the speech will
never be worth speaking enough.
I,
a little while ago had a very clear
experience of this.
I read about it on the radio in Britain
where I was in discussion with a Muslim
cleric who was sort of reformist
figuring meyer in some ways who in a
discussion about something said,
well,
you know,
also Muhammad Prophet Muhammad,
peace be upon him.
Was,
was he took criticism in his and he took
criticism very,
very well.
He never mind that.
People criticizing him.
I was like,
that's absolute crap.
That is real crap.
I mean,
whatever else you can say.
He Mohammed not really good on this,
on the criticism of himself bit.
And I gave an example of a female
protests who he had killed because she
criticized him and this guy went
absolutely ape shit and refused to
continue and so on.
And because you gave an actual
historical example from his own
religious texts and uh,
and in the end it was a prerecorded CNN,
the BBC,
I can this,
can you find another way of trying to
make the same point and you know,
and,
and that was what we had to do.
Another way of making the same point
rather than pointing out the historical
pxe that showed that Mohammed did have a
female poet killed.
Yes.
You just one other
way.
Would there be to make that point?
That is hard,
but that's the ultimate way to make that
point.
Exactly.
Which is by pointing to the texts and
the facts.
But you know,
I can think of no other situation in
which somebody has veto rights like
that.
Yeah.
In a normal discussion.
And it's because they are terrified of
the retaliation.
So,
I mean,
I knew everyone in the production box
was like,
oh no,
what's Douglas Dunn?
So how can we stop it affecting us?
What was this clerics response to that
he.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
went.
Yeah,
there's a bit nuts and wouldn't continue
unless I wouldn't say that.
And so what did he deny that it was?
Oh yeah.
I said I was making it up and I was a
liar.
I'm used to that,
but that,
that's a crazy thing for him to say when
someone could just read the text.
Yeah.
But they were banking on nobody doing
that.
Well,
not this day and age.
Don't bank on that.
Yeah,
I.
This is.
This is one of the releasing things,
isn't it?
Because although it's true,
you can suppress a lot of this.
You know,
we do live in an age when basically
anyone can google and find texts and
they can just find a time that a billion
people have read.
I'm not sure they've read it,
but yeah.
Well possess it.
How many people you think read it?
How many people you think read the
Bible?
Like if you had like,
guess there are a number of Christians
in this country.
All those tests aren't that they'd
sometimes to the humanists sudden did a
few years ago asking very basic
questions of self professed Christians
about their knowledge of the texts and
very few.
My favorite is self professed Christians
with religious tattoos.
Like,
hey man,
you got to read the whole book.
Like you are literally showing on your
skin that you didn't read the whole
book.
It didn't pay attention to don't do
that.
This is Leviticus,
leviticus.
It says that it's got the implications
against the writing.
I say if you read limited,
there's a heck of a lot you can't do.
If you.
If,
if you go down Leviticus,
I can't wear two pieces of different
cloth.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
Leviticus is a wonderful book.
It's going to be.
It's very good for them because what?
The Vegas wasn't the one which was the
book where the guy.
I'm called upon the sheet bear to kill
the children who were mocking his
baldness.
Do you know about that one?
My favorite special bald guy.
This guy was getting mocked by children
fucking kids and God called upon a.
She bear to come down and tear apart
these children who were making fun of
his bald head here.
Oh,
oh shit.
And the to bear to kings.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Wow.
Went up to pat.
If you are going to intervene in human
affairs for anything,
this would be the time when God's got to
step in this kind of stuff.
Going young kids,
young kids came out from the city and
mocked him and said to him,
go up you bald head.
Go up you bald head,
which is very mild,
and when he looked behind him and saw
them,
he cursed them in the name of the Lord,
all caps than two female bears came out
of the woods and tore up 42 lads have
their number and he went from there to
Mount Carmel.
It's like no big deal.
It's over.
Got It done.
And that's,
that's.
Yeah,
that's my favorite reading from
scripture was about the end of one of
the books that come in.
Which one?
It was over the course when I was young
and I always made me laugh if there was
a destruction of the city of Nineveh.
It finished,
I think not any finish this chapter of
the book,
he says,
you know,
and,
and low in that,
in that city where
40,000
human souls that were destroyed and had
also some cattle cattle just by
association,
some cattle,
bad cows.
There are bad cows.
God had a fuck up those cows too.
But no,
the um,
the bald headed one.
That's,
that's,
that's uh,
yeah,
that's a heck of a time to,
to tread into him to,
in an insult,
you know,
had your bald head is just an accurate
description.
I mean that is not an insult.
If you like,
you ugly,
sloppy,
baldheaded loser.
Okay.
Then maybe God needs to step in and send
some wolves to attack yet.
And why do they specify that they're
female?
Yeah.
Why is it female 30 to have that number?
Forty two kids.
Two bears head.
Those are some bitch ass kids need to
learn how to run.
That doesn't even make sense.
How the fuck those bears even catch all
42 of those kids.
What kind of kids they raised over there
in Bethel.
Alright.
Shouldn't get the fuck out of there.
Well,
they're all sitting around waiting their
turn mean trying out curse words to
causes the best to come down you shaggy
bear.
That didn't work.
You Shaggy.
Mangy.
Dirty,
stinky,
bare bulb.
Yeah.
There's so many of those stories that
are so strange.
I bet.
I bet that most,
if we,
if we were to go to the,
the people who say that that question is
in the polls and ask them about,
we don't even need to go to the bolthead
bad.
They don't accept that.
Most people don't even bother reading
that because it's just,
it's almost too crazy.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but,
but I'm very,
very little knowledge even about very
basic things.
Um,
uh,
you know,
even commandments and so on.
So that's the case with the religion
that in America and Britain is known
best with Christianity.
So there's no reason to assume that
that's not the case with Islam as well.
Isn't
that just the case with people?
I mean,
it seems to be the same thing that we're
talking about with headlines.
Someone reads a headlines,
they don't bother reading into it and
then they accuse someone of something.
It's almost like with religion,
I'm a Christian and I'm a Christian man.
Oh really?
Please me about the Bible,
right?
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
That's something I've often thought.
This is one of the reasons why it's
possible to get a sudden fanaticism
going within Muslim communities on some
issues to do with best for me is I think
is to do with,
uh,
a realization of this.
You said that this was the case about
our prophet.
I didn't know that.
I know he did what I had all my adult
life with,
with,
uh,
arguing with Muslims about things the,
they very rarely know for the problems
in their own tradition.
And when you bring them up,
they're like,
what the,
what he did,
what a,
like the Christians with the bold bets.
And this causes a really serious problem
for them because they are told from the
cradle that the,
that they are following a religion
founded by the most perfect man
imaginable.
And if you discover that,
if you know there's no description of
Helen,
of troy in ancient text,
why does nobody described handled?
Why doesn't it reset the unit?
She was so you had this beautiful blonde
ringlets order is because it actually
catches on as a,
as a theme because everyone makes Helen
of troy,
their most beautiful woman.
If you start describing,
you'd be like,
I'm not into red heads.
Everyone would write hello toy becomes a
person upon whom you put all of those
things and in the same way Mohammed
becomes,
if you say,
is the perfect human being,
people will just throw their lives,
put the kinds of things they think are
perfect onto Mohammed.
You must have been very kind,
very generous,
very caregiving,
and so on,
so that if you then say,
well,
what about when he vented this?
I think it just causes an extra hurt.
This is something we'll have to get
over,
of course,
because we can't go away and not
identify these,
these issues.
Um,
but it causes in the short term and
enormous,
enormous pain.
I have an example I gave recently in a
book of,
um,
somebody I spent some time with a couple
years ago to extraordinary man called
morten storm.
Um,
he was a Danish biker,
a big in a biker gang in Denmark.
I went to prison and in prison about
$2,000.
So he converted to Islam.
He converted to Al Qaeda.
Basically.
He's not a,
not a common person in any way,
and uh,
he ended up being the main go to person
for some of our luck.
He was the head of al Qaeda in Yemen and
in fact was asked to give him a,
get a wife our lucky to supplement his
wife collection and a modesto among
other things,
ended up falling out with our kid and
ended up working for the CIA and Danish
intelligence and ended up helping lead
them to our lucky who was then droned by
Obama in 2011 or so.
Anyhow,
I said to motor storm,
what was the moment that made you get
out of Al Qaeda?
And he has such a fascinating on.
So he,
he,
he came out of al Qaeda and Islam the
same moment.
He says what was happening was he was
sitting in his,
he was waiting for a package when kind
of drop off to get them from him to our
lucky and the,
the,
the person carrying the package was late
and then really late and he was sitting
in his apartment somewhere in Germany I
think at that point.
And he was so pissed off about this and
he had a laptop that was there on the
table and he thought basically,
how can I express my pissed off with my
al Qaeda colleagues for wasting my time
like this so much.
And he went to Google and typed in
contradictions in Islam and began to
read.
Wow.
That was how he got out.
That's what did him in.
Someone's being late.
He just started reading again.
They told me this,
they never told me that.
I never knew that.
And that was.
So.
As I say,
he's a very,
very uncommon.
But,
but I think that might be happening
quite a lot more than we know people.
Just googling things,
finding stuff out for themselves.
It's the most dangerous route.
Religion to leave because they kill
apostates.
I do.
Yeah.
So how is he dealing with that?
Well,
he,
he lives in hidings.
I mean.
Wow.
Yeah.
We didn't see me.
He wrote a book called agents dorm about
it two years ago.
One of the weirdest conversation that I
ever saw anybody have with someone who
is a believer was Dawkins.
I think it was was having a conversation
with someone and he asked him point
blank whether or not he believed that
Mohammed split the moon.
Oh yes.
I think I know this was with Vaco is
enemy of mine called Media Hassan who
worked for Al Jazeera and who Richard
Dawkins did an interview with and I
think he,
that's why he fluffed something earlier
on a dog is that he didn't take it on.
Then he took him on this.
That's right.
And I think that Sun City,
yes,
yes.
And then it lead to this terrible
problem which is really interesting and
distinct problem of our era,
which is then dog.
He said,
I can't believe that somebody or said
afterwards,
I can't believe that somebody can be a
working journalist and believe that,
you know,
Mohammed slipped and half human horse.
Right.
Um,
and of course,
I mean that's an interesting point
there,
but of course we do quite rightly allow
people to believe
bizarre and insane thing that
Christianity was bizarre.
Exactly.
And if we started saying you can't have
public office or work in journalism,
if you profess to be of this particular
then,
but we wouldn't get anyway.
We wouldn't have anyone left.
And how does the story go?
Mohammed flew to the moon on a half
human horse and split the moon with a.
is that what he did?
I can't remember.
He could have then been attacked by
female beds,
but I can't remember.
No,
I can't.
Yes,
he gets the night journey,
which is a central.
Has the moon get glued back together
again?
Is it glued back together?
It looks like it is.
I haven't looked close.
Maybe I need to pay more attention to
the fact that a,
I,
I believe this was a few years ago,
let's just say it was 2010 that this
interview or the debate took place
around them eight years ago that someone
would be comfortable saying,
oh,
that they believe that,
let me see.
I got into a little bit of trouble.
Richard Dawkins got a bit annoyed about
me,
uh,
because I took the mickey out of him for
dodging the one earlier in that it was
the earlier one.
He,
I'm a great admirer of Richard,
uh,
is everyone is sure.
But,
um,
he,
he knows exactly where the cliff edge
is.
And in that interview he,
uh,
he was asked on allergies era by this
interview.
He see read out the bit from the God
delusion about,
uh,
as a great bit of rhetoric about the
most,
the swipes God is something like the
most appalling,
narcissistic,
murderous,
blah,
blah.
Character in all of fiction is a
terrific piece of writing.
And the interviewer says to you,
you,
uh,
you stand by.
That was the description of the
Christian.
God says,
yes.
He says,
use it as a description of the Jewish.
God says yes.
Then he says,
and what do you say?
The same thing about the Muslim God.
And I just knew exactly what's
happening.
And Richard Dawkins says about the
Muslim God,
I didn't know so much,
which he,
as I say,
he,
he thinks I shouldn't rip him on this.
And the thing was,
what I noticed was just,
I just,
I completely felt it's been very brave
and brilliant writer and thinker on
these matters and nobody's done more in
some ways,
but he,
I knew exactly what was happening.
He was staring right over the cliff edge
and somebody was behind him,
nudging and that if he had said,
as it were,
live on Al Jazeera,
Oh yes,
Allah,
you know,
the total bastard,
then I,
you know,
you didn't know,
maybe that's maybe your then in real
trouble,
you know.
And so he stepped back from the brink
and I rather cruelly perhaps taking the
mickey out of him afterward.
I said that it was just the,
Richard Dawkins was demonstrating the
survival instinct of his species.
But I feel bad about it,
but it is true.
It is true.
But we've all been there to some extent.
And what was his response to that
though?
To my junior criticism?
He,
um,
well he basically,
he,
I think he did take it on board in a
way,
um,
complex reasons,
but I know,
I know,
I know he was also annoyed that I was
where he,
I think he felt that I was doing that to
him.
Then you do it right.
Right,
right.
Um,
and that is very common in that I've had
that a lot in my life in this particular
area of people trying to egg me over.
Why don't you say that course and uh,
and you know that they're the people
who'll be a million miles behind you
with their ears plugged.
Yeah.
I behind a wall.
I always have.
I always have a very,
very visual aid of era.
Somebody who actually is,
is a terrific reformer in Islam that now
under another cleric who wants to
describe me.
He went to fight for the Mujahideen in
Afghanistan and a study years ago now.
And describe to me that he's not a very
fittingly like person,
but described how he did that to sort of
rile them up to sort of run over and get
at the Soviets.
And he was like,
you know,
we're all agreed.
Yes,
yes.
And I go and he worked 20 odd guys.
Yeah.
Isn't everyone else stayed in the
trench?
And I've always thought this is exactly
the,
uh,
the experience of anyone.
Yeah.
This area is that there's an inherent
danger in this criticism.
Even this discussion right now,
I'm sure there's people right now firing
up their webcams and writing blogs and
tweeting and getting upset about it.
It's awesome.
Any rational discussion of that
particular subject,
you could kind of get away.
I mean,
I get criticism from Christians,
but it's not scary,
right?
Yes.
That is,
that,
that is a big difference at the time
doing isn't it?
This is this just something that's so
important to a nuance that almost never
gets added in.
But of course we all just assume it so
we don't think it's worth saying,
but we are aware that any religion or
for like this could be this dangerous at
different phases.
Yes.
Might've wanted to be in Spain in
certain points in the last millennium.
Sure.
Um,
we might not have,
wanted to be a Catholic center at
certain points or Protestant descend to
others,
and so on and so forth.
We all know that,
yes,
it's just that at the moment that's
pretty crescent and uh,
and quiet.
And of course it's less quiet here than
it is in my country on condo.
Imagine the Anglican church becoming
militant about anything at any point
soon.
A,
you do have some angry or types of
Christian here than we have in my
country.
And so it's easy for me to think they're
slightly less,
uh,
risky at some point in the future than
the new might.
But,
but it's just that we do recognize this
could happen elsewhere as well.
It just,
at the moment it's,
it's,
it's not the quakers that they really
don't send me a death threat from one
year to the next rather nice people.
There is an inherent danger of a
retaliation from people who are more
radical Christian,
that if this continues and if you see
more and more of more and more attacks
from people of Muslim faith,
you could possibly see a retaliation
from people.
Especially in this country,
like after nine slash 11,
there was an extreme amount of,
of hate for Muslims and irrational hate
done.
Nothing wrong to the Sikhs as I
remember.
Yes.
Well,
there was a lot of that out of
ignorance.
They just didn't.
They didn't.
I mean that was the most disturbing
because Sikhs are pretty interesting
people and the fact that they just
instantaneously with no information at
all,
no understanding out of complete
ignorance attack them.
Uh,
I,
I have a second to no one in my
gloominess about some of the things that
we're going to go through in Britain and
Europe in the coming years.
But I recently had a reason to even more
gloomy about one aspect of it relating
to this,
which is this.
We had a three big bad terrorist attacks
last year in,
uh,
in the UK,
including the Manchester Arena bomb.
Twenty two young people were blown up on
a Monday night for going to hear Ariana
Grande Day.
Um,
and uh,
after the third of those attacks,
which was on London Bridge,
when a three people who are actually
known to authorities as they generally
are a slash people's throats on the
street and ran to borough market is
people were drinking and stabbed.
People are shouting.
This is for Allah.
After the third of those attacks,
it was felt like,
Oh God,
is this really just got to keep
happening?
What are we going to do about it and
what can we do?
And after the Manchester one in
particular,
there was this kind of thing of everyone
saying,
apart from John Lennon's imagine there
was the oasis hit,
don't look,
don't look back in anger and these
themes that we weren't meant to think
anything other than that we weren't
meant to be angry and went.
And uh,
then then just a terrible thing happened
from another direction,
uh,
outside Finsbury Park mosque,
which the muscular,
very troubled and bad history in London.
I'm a guy from Wales in a van,
drives into the crowds as the milling
around outside the mosque,
kills one man and enjoys a number of
others.
Uh,
that guy,
by the way,
just show how complex all this can get.
His,
uh,
he was tried,
found guilty last month in the courts in
the UK.
Uh,
he,
uh,
he had been,
he loves you very mentally deranged and
had a history of mental illness and all
that sort of thing is very often people
do in these situations.
But he,
uh,
he had watched the BBC drama called
three girls,
which is a first time that the BBC had
really addressed the issue of the rather
than Rochdale rape gangs.
That happened in the last decade in the
UK,
which is still a sore that's going on.
We're about 1500 girls in one town
alone.
We're basically a abused by gangs,
most of them,
mainly Pakistani men,
and it's a very,
very ugly business partly because it was
so awful that nobody that nobody at the
state and the police level and he wanted
to look into it.
They are now the government inquiries
that they didn't look into it so worried
about being called racist and
Islamophobia console.
The press did a lot of not being
interested in this as well.
Eventually after all these years of BBC
makes a documentary called three girls,
about three of the girls who have
suffered from these rape gangs and then
a man in Wales sees it and get so
enraged people say at the local pub he
was railing against the bloody Muslims
and all this sort of thing,
and then he hires a van and drives into
a crowd of people outside a mosque and
you have this awful feeling that the BBC
didn't want to deal with the issue that
the program was about for years because
it was so awful and ugly and sounded
like something made up by some kind of
nativist,
racist,
you know,
it's,
uh,
it's had everything.
Um,
and then they do.
And then it turns out the member of the
public sees it and drove the van into a
crowd.
I mean,
you know,
this,
this sort of couldn't get more complex.
And so I thought after that,
okay,
maybe,
maybe the,
maybe the BBC were right.
Maybe they shouldn't.
Maybe they should cover up the gangway
per 1500 girls.
Maybe the public can't cope with it.
Maybe they will get into vans now as it
happens.
I know the British public,
I think fairly well and I think that
that guy in Wales a very,
very unusual figure.
I don't think it's very common.
I don't think everyone's going to do
that.
I don't think we're all like that wicked
mad,
but I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know for sure everywhere.
I don't know what the.
I don't know what happened in this
country.
Have various other countries.
If there were three attacks like that in
quick succession,
I don't know,
but this is.
This is really.
It's just going to get complex is
already complex
and the response to it,
it's complex too.
How do you,
how do you,
if you,
if you are a journalist,
if you are a television channel,
how do you report on this?
Do you think about the responsibility of
alerting someone to these actual real
atrocities?
It's going to force them to react on
innocent people that did nothing in
front of this mosque and the fact that
these people in this mosque or somehow
or another connected to these people
that did these horrible crimes just by
virtue of the fact they're in the same
religion.
That's insane to.
Yeah,
it's all insane
to me.
The only way through it is to say,
first I read it,
I can press all the time and I think
that it's worse than the British press
in,
in that self appointed role of believing
it's task is to stand between the public
and the facts,
you know,
and sort of negotiate between the two,
uh,
see what they think the public can cope
with or should know,
and then feed them that I'm the American
press teams to be rife with that.
That temptation as ours is.
But it seems to be the only way around
this is to not,
not given to that and to try just to
publish the fact when they happen
because it's just obviously seems to be
much worse.
We will know in political scandal what's
worse,
the cover up.
It's always the cover up and that that
may be the case with all of this.
Maybe,
maybe the,
the argument for just the papers
explaining stuff that's happened is
maybe that's maybe that's all they can
do and that it won't be just say to them
it'd be a lot worse if you bottled this
up because otherwise people will get the
idea that there is some conspiracy to
cover over certain stories and they'll
be onto something.
In fact,
if you think about the millions of
people that must have seen that the
story on the grape of 1500,
the fact that only one person responded
that way is pretty extraordinary in and
of itself.
Yes,
yes.
I,
I would've,
I would've thought on some of this.
I mean,
you know,
I don't know.
Again,
I mean there are,
there are lots of examples aren't good
use,
but when something bad happens,
like the Manchester Arena attack,
uh,
I'm,
I'm amazed in a way that people are so
decent.
I mean,
I'm so pleased they are,
but they,
we really,
we don't go out looking for people to
attack,
you know,
the,
the public.
Certainly in Britain I can happily send,
I think it's the same in America public,
but we were not really lynch mobs
waiting to be got going again,
but the expectation that we are,
is there any possibility of creating us
in such a way?
Um,
it's only by treating us as if we can't
deal with ugly things that go on the,
you could see the situations where he
began to see the situation in which that
all goes wrong in that different way.
Yeah.
I mean I don't envy their position,
especially trying to pick up the ball
from here.
Yes.
With all the history and all the
terrible things,
especially in England with so many
attacks over such a relatively short
period of time where there was a very
small history of that before.
It seemed like this immediate eruption
of all these issues.
Yes,
the country in some ways I wrote about
in my lates,
but most is France where the book comes
out in translation there and a couple of
months time we're very interested to see
what happens because France even,
I mean we mentioned Charlie Hebdo,
but that 18 months or so it had was
just,
I mean again,
we'd all sort of disappeared now
everyday he's got bad news of some kind,
but you know,
to have a um,
a major western capital city with 130
people killed in an evening with
multiple suicide bombings and people
being gunned down from mopeds as they're
sitting outside a bar and you know,
another group of people going into a
rock concert and you know,
going through the disabled section,
shooting everyone one by one in the
disabled,
actually catch them in the lavatories
and shooting them.
And I mean the,
that happened in one night alone in
Paris.
The Parisians didn't become,
you know,
they didn't become wicked terrible
people or anything,
but they have.
I think these,
I think that the,
a lot of these terrible events that
happening,
they actually,
what happens is they sink down to a
lower level of our consciousness so that
we,
what actually happens is we,
we get over the immediate thing quite
fast,
but something at the foundational level
changes.
I had a case nobody really wants to
linger on,
but there was one in November in the UK
on Oxford Street wear because of course
everyone does.
After these attacks,
they always say,
you know,
we will not be changed.
Everyone tries to sort of channel the
spirit of Churchill and all that sort of
thing.
Um,
in church you'll hear me roar.
And,
and so and uh,
and actually the,
the facts are otherwise.
In November on Oxford Street,
there was,
all we know is that there were two men
who may have had some disagreement on
the platform of a tube.
The tube platform,
whatever happened,
it was misunderstood by crowds and it
developed into a stampede out of the
tube station and all the way down Oxford
street people were locked and barricaded
into the big department stores.
A,
a pop singer called polymers,
uh,
tweeted out his million followers,
you know,
there are shots are being fired.
I'm in the back room of the store,
h and m and this sort of thing.
And uh,
other people claim that the truck had
gone down.
Oxford mowing people down,
they've seen bodies.
The police said it was a major terrorist
event.
They were on top of it.
And the press were all,
you know,
running stories turned out nothing
happened.
Nothing happened.
The next day,
two men handled themselves into a local
police station saying,
I thought they might have been
responsible for it,
but they will let off without any
charge.
What I'm saying is
they thought they might be responsible
for it because they had been in an,
they'd had an argument,
maybe they,
they weren't saying we're responsible,
healthy,
but like do they ask asking for
information and they will let go.
But the point is,
is that is that we,
we,
we can simultaneously say we will not be
cowed and also actually be at the stage
where if you just hear a bang,
everyone goes running
you,
you don't want to be the last person to
figure out what's going on.
Hmm.
So as soon as something you think is
happening,
people in this day and age when there's
just this recent history of horrible
things happening over and over again in
Orlando here,
I mean there's just so many of them that
people just instantaneously want to
react and then liking the vegas
shooting.
One of the things that was very
confusing about the vegas shooting is
people would go into casinos,
they would flee from the concert into
casinos and then talk about a shooter,
and then people would say there's an
active shooter at the Tropicana.
There's an active choice.
That's why I never believed that
immediate aftermath.
There's a claim of other other shooters.
There's always a claim or something that
turns out not okay.
Everywhere there were,
there were claiming your shooters all
over the city,
but there was no actual shooting in
these other casinos who just reports of
active shooter.
Yeah,
and by the way,
if you're interested,
there's a fascinating thing about why
this happens and I read a book some
years ago about bloody Sunday,
terrible event in Northern Ireland in
1972 and one of the things I went
through all the tests that we have,
everyone who has seen one of the most
interesting things was the number of
people whose memories,
which is totally different from what we
know actually happened and one of the
conclusions I came to is that there's a
book by Harvard professor,
but the called the seven sins of memory
about this.
But one of the things that clearly
happened is after one very traumatic
event or have a terrible event where
people are effectively in the situation
of a war zone,
when they were just shopping.
The constantly moment before is that our
memories immediately become even more
suggestible than they are already.
And the most obvious thing of
suggestibility in these situations is
that the situation was,
was worse around you and you came off
better than you did.
And that's almost always the case.
Um,
the,
the shots that were quite,
uh,
quite a bit away,
we're very close.
Um,
uh,
you,
you have your memory without knowing it,
I will do it.
Our memory tells us we behave better
than we did and the threat was worse
because this is our,
one of our ways of coping I think.
Um,
but,
but it's a terrible thing.
And obviously with,
I mean with these school shootings and
things that are going on here at the
moment.
I mean,
this is obviously one of the things I
watched your podcast the other day where
you were discussing it.
So the latest one with the Florida and
uh,
and I think sort of in a way bafflement
going on in this society about this is
understandable.
Yeah.
The,
I mean,
it's the unimaginable horror of being
involved in that situation.
Your mind is just not prepared to cope
with that.
I mean,
maybe if you're a soldier and if you
experienced combat and you know how to
stay calm and a firefight because you've
been in a bunch of them,
but for the average person,
I mean it's one of the reasons why I
witness testimonies.
One of the worst pieces of evidence you
could ever get,
including I mean,
about it,
about basically everything about fist
fights,
you know?
Oh yeah,
no,
I.
We all have examples in our lives.
I've seen friends who've been through
the same thing.
We know that they burned through the
same thing and yet they have two totally
different directions.
Of course,
you know what happened.
I mean that's,
that's a real problem,
but now you have this thing here where,
I mean in some ways even worse than we
do have of the search to notch it up for
your own political science or against
the enemy.
It's the same thing with a twitter,
the twitter point,
but the.
I mean this,
this obscene glee that goes on after any
terrorist attack in Europe,
but I think also here's what the attempt
is to immediately call it for the other
side or for your site or whatever and to
to try to use terrible events as a way
to justify whatever your team is.
Yes,
I have I find is amazing with the gun
debate here and I would find it amazing
coming from a different society on it,
but the wages are not set up for one
side or the other in it and it's.
You've got a real
problem on this.
I've been watching a lot of it from the
perspective of the gun owners,
NRA members and the people that want to
defend the idea of having guns even of
arming teachers and you're looking at
their perspective on it and their
perspective on it is all about their
rights.
All about the constitution,
all about the bill of rights,
all about protecting the second
amendment,
all about gun ownership being taken
away,
gun ownership,
under attack,
the NRA under attack.
They're coming after our guns and this
is this constant battle of ideas.
It's on twitter,
not addressing the actual issue.
Sorry.
No,
it's okay.
It's to.
I'm watching this thing.
Arming teachers.
Yeah.
That's insane.
I mean,
this is Samuel Jackson had a great quote
about it,
but you know,
he uh,
he put it on twitter.
Like someone tell a motherfucker was
never been in a gunfight.
The problems of arming a bunch of
teachers,
right?
Somebody that someone who's been in a
gunfight,
please tell.
Yeah.
Motherfuckers,
somebody.
Somebody said,
anyone who thinks is a good idea.
Giving teachers guns as quitting.
Never seen one.
Try to use an overhead projector.
Yeah,
there is.
There Samuel Jackson.
Look at that 306,000
likes.
So,
you know,
it was an effective tweet.
They,
the world we're living in and he just
checked the number.
It wasn't like,
yeah,
you got three tweets.
It can't be true.
Nobody likes.
Yeah,
I,
I felt that was a very pertinent one a
few years ago in New York on fifth when
somebody shot their colleague and I'm
outside the office,
came back with a disgruntled worker,
the Carnegie and uh,
locally there were some policemen around
the corner and they came out and started
firing at the guy who'd done it,
ended up wounding around 11 pedestrian
like,
well,
you would,
wouldn't you?
Of course,
I mean,
I'm not saying by the way,
but we have,
we have our own problems,
but I mean this is a big problem for
America and what I can have more guns
and we have people.
I mean,
I completely understand why the
amendment exists and I think it's a very
good idea for the time and I think it's
a very understandable.
I did hold onto it now,
but,
um,
but why can't people say for instance,
I mean,
we all have abstract ideas we have to
hold onto,
but we were all in our countries have
like weird things that other people
don't understand.
I mean,
you might think it's odd to have a
hereditary constitutional monarch for
instance.
And,
uh,
it,
it is weird,
it's a great way to put it.
It didn't seem strange and uh,
if you were starting from now,
you might not do that.
Um,
uh,
but,
but clearly with the ownership thing,
it is,
we are willing to take bad things
happening quite often because we want to
hold onto
the second amendment.
Well,
the second amendment has been around
forever.
The bad things happening quite often is
really from columbine on.
I mean,
there was a few of them before the,
there was the Austin,
Texas,
uh,
but,
tower shootings.
But it seems like,
I mean,
again,
I mean just,
it's such an obvious point.
I don't want to sound like it was high.
It's not a Brit who's saying something
about America that's not at all
welcomed,
but it seems obvious that you just,
you could do a lot more damage with a
semiautomatic rifle than you can with a
knife.
And most people,
we see this in the terrorism as well
where there are really committed
terrorists who don't commit acts of
violence unless they can get hold of,
uh,
of,
the means to do it because we often
think,
well,
why don't you just like go out with a
knife?
Some people do,
but most people actually want to go out
in that way and what they see as being a
blaze of glory.
Right?
So they like stopping them.
Having the means of getting that very
easily.
Seems to me very obvious.
But that isn't to say that.
I mean,
of course I think you made a point the
other day and it's like saying if you
say everyone who has a gun is part of
promise and obviously not because it's
like saying everyone who's got a truck
is about the problem.
But there is,
there are obviously two things.
One is the psychological and whatever
the social issues are that caused this
to keep happening and that,
that is obviously very,
very important to try to get to the root
of.
But you can get to the root of that or
try to get through to that and also
recognize that people having access to
some of the weapons they have access to
in this country must be a part of the
problem problem
it has to be.
And they're also the idea that you
should just be able to go out and buy a
gun without really understanding how a
gun works at all.
Yeah.
And which is exactly how you do it.
I got my first handgun license in 1994.
That's when I bought my first hand gun
and I just went and bought a handgun.
But I did a background check on me.
That's it.
I mean I went to the range.
They showed me what the safety is,
pointed this,
put the earphones on,
make sure you don't blow yours out,
Bang,
Bang.
And then you leave the gun.
I mean,
once your background checks clear,
they find out you're not a criminal.
There's not much to it.
There's A.
There's a giant problem with that.
If you want to drive an automobile,
you have to show that you understand the
laws.
You have to understand,
you have to sit with an expert was to
sit there and driving instructor to have
to go through it with you.
They have to watch your movements.
They have to watch you make turns.
They wouldn't,
wouldn't you imagine that it would be a
good idea to have some sort of a
clinical evaluation of a person that's
gonna going to buy a gun,
and here's another thing.
There was an article recently that was
saying contrary to popular belief,
most school shootings not committed by
people who are mentally ill will.
That's a fucking stupid thing to say.
You know why?
Because if you're screaming,
you're committing a school shooting,
you're mentally ill.
Okay,
period.
Then on top of that,
what they're ignoring conveniently,
and this is another headline thing,
psychiatric medications,
these people are almost entirely on some
form of psychiatric medication,
whether it is anti anxiety pills,
whether it's antidepressants with there
they are all.
I'm not saying that correlation equals
causation.
I'm not saying that,
but to say that they're not.
This is just a bullshit,
this is click bait headlines.
They're mentally ill,
100 percent,
100 percent of them are mentally ill
as a conservative commentator in the UK
called Peter Hitchens,
who always makes a point after Islamist
terrorist attacks in Europe that there's
a large number of them as well as other
types of attack who seemed to be on some
kind of medication and my point is
always I'm very,
very happy to have that conversation.
I think we need to have that
conversation and we also have to have
the other parts of it as well.
Yes,
so it's the same here.
I can't see why we can't have all of
this.
It's the same thing that we were talking
about earlier.
It's this idea of sports.
These wars people don't want to give up
their idea.
They don't want to give up any ground
whatsoever on their second amendment
rights.
Whether it's owning a 50 caliber fucking
tank gun or whether it's having a gun
for home safety or for hunting.
They don't want to give up anything and
they feel like it's a slippery slope.
The people that I follow online that are
tweeting about this on a regular basis
and you can go to a lot of them like
they're making videos about it.
Dana Lash and Collin is actually,
his name is collins,
Cole Lion,
colion noir and.
Oh,
I are.
He's very,
very vocal about it.
I'm,
I'm reading all this stuff.
It's like all anyone's taking into
account is that this idea that they're
coming after your rights and and
emphasizing the idea of a good person
with a gun that can protect people in
these terrible situations which can
happen as well,
but what we have to address it.
That's not what we're talking about.
We have to address how the fuck do these
crazy people get guns?
Why?
Why are so many people on mental health
medication?
Well,
that's a huge,
a huge fund and we always have one thing
to have the conversation about it,
but there's very little done on it.
That's one thing.
I'm very struck by this.
We have in all our countries,
I slipped into a very weird attitude
towards this type of medical.
Okay.
Yes.
Very weird.
Very just very accepting of something
that radically alters the way your mind
works
and maybe it's maybe it's not an
incentive.
Drug companies obviously don't have an
incentive quite the opposite and to look
into it,
but it's another example of the set of
set of things we should be thinking
about at the moment,
looking at which we just don't.
Why don't we,
because it's sort of shut down because
we shut it down ourselves.
I,
uh,
I think it's just a such a range of
issues.
This is the case with and it's always
the same thing.
It's always that if you address the
question difficult as it might be,
you are attacking an individual who
might suffer from it,
who might be upset by US addressing the
question.
I mean,
I have a lot of suspicions about all
sorts of things.
I'm a very skeptical person.
Is it worried about things that I'm
told.
So I'd like to look into things.
I'm amazed at the number of things in,
in our societies that we just don't
discuss net all the things that we ought
to be discussing.
Um,
issues like mental health issues,
uh,
issues that have to do with a social
presumptions that are going on left,
right and center at the moment where
you're not meant to discuss things that
have popped into me.
I was very,
very interesting and very important.
Um,
and I just see it everywhere.
this might,
by the way,
so this is a slightly strange segue to
make,
but there was a fascinating one in in
Britain a couple of days ago,
a slightly lighter subject,
but there was not that much.
But,
um,
there's a dive in the UK called Tom
Daley who married a screenwriter from
Hollywood called Dustin Lance black.
And it was announced a couple of weeks
ago on Valentine's Day that they were
having a baby and there was a photograph
of them holding a scan.
They sent out on their twitter.
The two men who are married who have
ultrasound scan and all of the papers
and the BBC and evidence report is
saying Dustin and Tom are having a baby.
And I mean,
I'm gay and I'm,
I don't think I'm homophobic,
but I looked at this as how,
how like someone else involved.
I mean,
in a joke,
gays,
uh,
you can't have children.
Doesn't mean we can't keep trying,
but I just loaded,
it has nothing in the articles about
this tells me anything I would like to
know,
like I know that they didn't just have a
role around and woke up in the morning
and one of them was [inaudible].
I know that.
And I know that there has to be a woman
involved at some point we know this,
but we are meant to just adapt.
Okay,
great.
Cool.
And it's almost as if it's set up so
that somebody says,
wait a isn't,
isn't,
isn't a woman,
isn't a uterus,
so that they're no longer is a big word,
right?
Racist,
sexist,
xenophobic.
Yeah.
Everything we've got.
Uh,
and,
and of course somebody did really well.
Somebody from the Daily Mail wrote a
column saying,
come on to dads isn't a new normal sort
of thing.
And of course then everyone piled in on
that.
And although he always advertises,
withdrew their advertising.
But this was just on,
this was like literally literally until
the day before yesterday.
It was possible to say I didn't think
two guys can just like,
have sex and make a tiled.
Literally that was okay until the day
before yesterday.
And it's not okay today.
So what will not be okay tomorrow?
And I just think,
I think,
and I wrote about it,
uh,
and uh,
maybe a couple other people ended up
doing it too.
But I think that's really interesting.
Like a lot of these answers.
I think it's really interesting about
this,
that you are the things that seem very
obvious to us are all the things you're
not meant to write about.
Almost as if they're like booby traps
where you need to go off and,
and I just think,
oh,
why don't more people pile on in because
we could have a heck of a time and we
might solve.
Well,
people don't want to pile in on anything
revolving involving gender or sexuality.
It's just too scary.
It's landmine field.
They can walk in,
especially as you said earlier,
people with regular jobs,
if you get called out for being a racist
or a homophobe or anything along those
lines,
you're doomed.
Sure.
It's,
um,
it.
But in that case,
anyone who does have a voice as a
writer,
a speaker,
whatever,
broadcaster,
I think has a disproportionate duty to
do so.
To do that.
I mean,
there's no point in just repeating those
same new lies,
uh,
the disproportion of duty to try to
break them down.
I remember one of my favorite quotes
that went from her mencken who says,
you know,
that history was always progressed by
jolly fellows,
heaving dead cats into sanctuaries and
going roy string down the highways of
the world.
And,
um,
uh,
I just,
I,
I wish that there were more dead cat
lovers because he's such a bad job.
You can make a living sometimes and um,
and it's,
it's,
it's one of the only things worth doing
if,
if we're all going to be told lies and
we expect you to go along with them,
whether it's about terrorism or,
or gay parenting or mental health or
anything else,
whole set of them.
It's a really target rich environment.
It is,
and I think there's more people doing
that now than ever before,
but it's more people like you and I who
can kind of get away with it.
Yeah,
I know.
What,
why do you think you'd get away with it?
By the way?
Me?
Because he can't take me seriously.
I'm a cage fighting commentator and a
dirty comedian.
Right?
Nobody's listening to me and take me
seriously in that regard.
Book sort of.
It's A.
I just.
First of all,
I'm a kind person.
I think that helps.
Like I'm not a mean person,
but what I'm saying,
these things I'm saying these things
from I'm going,
what,
what the fuck is this?
Like,
here's one that I thought was really
fascinating and this is one of the great
example of how strange we get on
subjects.
Uh,
Caitlyn Jenner,
when,
when Caitlyn Jenner transitioned,
that was the primary thing that people
were talking about.
Oh my God,
she's a woman now and it was right after
she had been spacing out behind the
wheel,
slammed into a woman and pushed her into
traffic and a head on collision and the
woman died.
And that was almost just completely
forgot.
Completely forgot.
Not only that,
she doesn't believe in gay marriage.
Right?
Like what?
You're,
you have the wrong spokesperson.
I mean,
you could not have a more wrong
spokesperson.
Yeah.
But yet espn and Glamor woman of the
year and all these different things and
athlete of the year is wearing dresses
and fabulous and Glam and let's get your
chin shaved down because that's who you
really are.
We really are.
Is not this person there.
No.
You gotTa,
you gotTa Shave your.
It's,
it's,
it's back to that thing about the.
Almost as if you're being dead.
Yes.
You're there to discuss it.
Because I said this to Sam Harris,
I got him into trouble just on his
podcast by saying this and he didn't
attack me.
Apparently he got a whole load of
transphobia accusations because of me
saying something.
But I said to him,
I thought what was happening was that we
were being asked not only to agree that
Caitlin Bruce Jenner became Caitlyn
Jenner.
The caitlyn Jenner was a woman,
but that,
but you have to find out.
Yes,
you have to say she's beautiful Shag and
Jenna,
you were just like.
And,
and I find those,
those ones are just,
there was one of the other way.
It's a bit like the gave her anything.
So it's like I dare you,
you just,
you just tried pretending,
pretending that tolman dusting can't
have a baby.
Um,
and,
and it was the same with a little while
ago,
there was a boy in Britain who was
iconic,
whether he wanted to turn up school and
address.
He's like nine years old.
And there was a route,
I can't remember.
The school said yes or no,
but it was a big thing.
And then it became like a weigh in on
the behalf of the nine year old Trans
Kid.
I got lots of questions to ask that.
And then it became a,
the,
the nine year old kid was,
was,
was uh,
became a model for a fashion shoot.
And then it's like,
find the nine year old boy who says he's
a girl.
Attractive and say it's beautiful.
How much more do you want to push
people?
Like,
no,
they were awarding.
They like,
like,
isn't she lovely?
Right?
What are you doing to us?
What are you trying to make us agree to?
Right.
Well,
what's,
what's the cause of all this?
Have you.
I mean,
you must've been talking about this,
like what?
This is this bizarre,
illogical conversation that falls into
these very convenient,
well cut grooves that you're really not
allowed to slide ideas out
of what's causing this.
I think it's a so many things I want is
one is that it's possible.
This is what happens when the economics
goes wrong.
I've got a feeling.
The economics,
I mean is that if people's,
if people aren't seeing it increases in
their living.
I mean,
my generation,
I'm 38,
uh,
by just above this generation,
but the generations ever so slightly
below me,
um,
is becoming aware that weren't,
get on the property ladder at all.
Maybe a property ladder,
meaning owning a home,
owning a home,
the things that their parents generation
got not easily by any means,
but it wasn't,
uh,
it wasn't easy for boomers,
but,
uh,
that,
that somehow they're going to have it
harder than their parents' generation.
Well,
might not enjoy the living standards of
the parents' generation.
Enjoyed,
might be certainly in western Europe
coming home.
It might be occurring to them.
What do you do in those such situations?
Um,
you've got to have other things to,
to get worth from.
If for instance,
you're not going to own a home until
you're 40 and that point,
if you're a woman at your career,
you need to have children,
but you can't afford to take the time
off work and you might not be able to
start a family and then you're trying to
start a family in your forties and it's
harder,
uh,
very hard and a whole set of other
things like that that are definitely
delayed for new generation.
And I think that it's possible.
I'm not saying certainly it's possible.
It seems to me that that generation
might discover new gods.
I might want to enforce the new rules
just as avidly as the old gods.
And there is an element of that girl.
I can't understand why.
Otherwise,
every time I talk about the things we
taught her say they would just
continuously be this very angry.
We actually not.
It's interesting.
You know,
I never thought that.
I think probably like,
you know,
I mean,
it's quite hard to shock me or to upset
me.
Uh,
you know,
and I can.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Or why do you think that?
Uh,
so why do I always get this?
Like we've got to stop him?
Uh,
other than that,
these are new commandments were breaking
and,
and why so,
and I mean they're all sort of
connected,
aren't they?
These things they're all attempts to,
but they're all attempts to something
like purity,
which disturbs me.
What sort of,
if we could just get everything in a
row,
you know,
you even hear that thing get in your
lane.
I hate the people who say that that's
all in your lane or do you think you are
a,
what's my lane?
I think I've said it a few times,
you know,
but I mean,
sorry,
but the only people that needed to stay
in their lane.
I'm different.
New York Times.
Yes.
I was reading on the plane over.
Okay,
now I'm reading your time on the planet
and uh,
and there's a,
there's a question as a,
uh,
you know,
w we call it,
what do you go south?
Hell,
whatever advice column this woman says
she was on the,
on the train covered days ago and there
was a man who came in with his
girlfriend.
He was being really abusive to her and
it just kept happening and he was
really.
It was kind of nasty ball and violence
situation.
She doesn't know what to do.
Other people in the case,
they will move away and of course you
can see what's coming.
The combination of it is she says she
gets off the train.
She wonders whether she should have said
something,
but she says conscious of her white
privilege and that these people were
people of color,
and I'm reading this.
I'm thinking,
what you you now now if you saw a man of
different skin pigmentation from you
abusing a woman,
have different skin pigmentation from
you.
The right thing is not to defend the
woman.
That seems like just a real
justification for being a coward.
Yes,
but,
but I found the advice was yeah,
now you did the right thing.
Maybe you should've spoken to an
official suddenly,
but there was no kind of.
So all this stuff,
all this weird get in your lane.
No,
no,
no.
You're a privileged way of your
privilege.
I mean,
that's a good way to make society have a
nervous breakdown.
Is Way up your privilege,
you know,
privilege scorecards.
I mean my God,
I am,
but,
but all of these things seem to.
It's almost as if people think if we get
the,
the lanes correct,
everything will be sorted and here's the
problem is first of all the means of
doing this.
It just hideous.
I mean hideous.
They accentuate racial difference.
They accentuates sexual and gender
differences and accentuate everything
else and the destination is horrible,
is not the nirvana they think that
they're creating.
So this is a really good moment to,
to try to look at some of this and to
talk about it and to think about as
widely and as freely as we can and yet,
and yet the effort is to do the
opposite.
I think you're onto something with the
idea that this radical progressive,
very restrictive line of communication
ideology that we're experiencing,
we're talking about is coming from a lot
of people that don't have a religion.
Yes,
there are atheists or they're at the
very least agnostics,
modern progressives.
Very rarely religious.
Yes,
and this must be for somebody who's a
nonbeliever like myself.
This is a painful thing to look at,
but again,
you have to think about it,
but that's.
Isn't that an interesting thing as well
because you think of yourself as being
on a team with these other atheists or
agnostics,
etc.
I don't,
but you don't,
but I'm saying as an atheist yourself,
you have to look at it that way.
You've already lumped yourself In with
them.
Yes.
I,
I speaking to campus in with us for a
while ago and I spoke to a,
a guy who's really,
really clever,
skewed into as a free thinker and he
said,
he said to the officers,
you were talking.
He said,
you know,
he'd have some hideous experience at a
local free thinkers society,
you know,
everyone was like,
get in your lane.
And he was like,
I thought that being among free
thinkers,
like the rest of it will be good.
I was like,
no,
no.
They,
uh,
the free thinkers turn out to be just as
able to be blindfolded if you,
you know,
on certain things down
when you imagine this,
of course self proclaimed free thinkers
would be even more inclined to adopt a
rigid ideology.
There are proclaiming themselves to be a
free
thinker.
And it's possible that this comes from
that,
you know,
the,
uh,
the old joke about sentences,
you know,
the,
the sensor knows everythIng that the
people who are really into.
And uh,
I spoke once to man who was on the
british board of film classification or
you said all day watching really
hardcore pornography,
deciding what can be legalized.
And the last thing,
you must have a dark view of humanity.
Well,
that's what justice wasn't justice
scalia's,
uh,
interpretation of pornography.
I don't know how to describe it,
but I'll know it when I see it exactly.
Like why are you a fucking judge?
And it may be,
but it may be that these people that a
lot of conservatives have this thing,
that one becomes rigid about something
because you've seen into the abyss
because you don't know.
You might behave in a certain very
terrible way and so you,
you,
you want to pull back from that chaos.
You want to pull other people back as
well.
Seems to me that a lot of circled free
thinker,
self designated free thing is may well
have these glimpses and may well think,
I don't know what's holding this
together and therefore might precisely
for that reason be disproportionately
rigid on almost any new ideology that
came along.
Getting lane.
Yeah.
I like it.
This idea that this is almost like a
substitution for religion.
It's almost like there's an inherent
need that we have because human beings
have operated under these patterns for
so long.
We clearly have this need.
It'd be upset.
Did pretend we didn't,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting because the more you,
like,
we found ways to market and one of the
ways to market and I think that that's
important and that mockery,
although it seems trivial,
what it does do is let people know how
ridiculous other people feel those ideas
are and then it makes them reexamined
themselves because they don't like being
mocked the term social justice warriors.
Wonderful for that because it just makes
you look like such a fucking fool.
I'm a social justice warrior.
It was a site that I was a colleague of
mine,
a spectator in london called the rod
little road a few years ago.
Any any man who says he's a feminist?
Clearly just as seeking a shag.
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
It's amazing.
One thing to want quality,
but to proudly state that you're a
feminist is it's almost.
I have joked around about it like,
I see what you're doing.
You don't run fast.
You can't pick things up.
That was like the fuck somebody said
it's about a,
the end
written.
Uh,
they said,
uh,
they described themselves as an anti
racist party and as a comedian who said
it actually makes,
makes you think they might be racist.
It'd be like saying your,
an ntp to affiliate children's agents.
See you think,
who is the community that said that
doesn't exist.
That's hilarious.
That's so true.
It's so true.
And so it's virtue signaling to the
highest degree.
It's like you're,
you're putting up your flag of,
of moral superiority standing on your
high ground.
But it is,
it is,
it,
it obviouslY means a great deal to talk
to these people,
but yeah,
but then the question is just how to,
how to invite them not to think like
that.
I think mockery mockeries one of the
best ways because it just lets them know
that other people think it's
preposterous,
so it's not achieving the desired
result.
The desired result is,
oh,
look at this amazing person is
incredible progressive ways of thinking.
Not like,
oh,
look at this transparent fuck who's just
trying to get laid.
you know,
that's,
that's how a lot of us see it,
but they don't see that.
We see it that way in some of the,
I mean,
it's a lot of ways.
A lot of our behavior is a,
it's experimental,
you know,
I mean,
people are experimenting with various
different ways of gaining a social
preference points.
Well,
this is,
this is why I always say even if even if
people aren't believers,
there were things that they can learn
from religion and from tradition.
And I've always thought that the,
um,
I've always thought there's one central
insight of the judeo christian
tradition,
which I wish that the social justice
warriors bore in mind.
And that is,
that's the garden of eden.
And,
and,
and the,
the,
the what we call the crooked timber of
humanitY.
Just just to recognize the central
truth,
which is in that tradition and in others
that we were not born in this situation
of research and a,
a perfection,
uh,
or goodness,
quite,
quite otherwise.
We are.
We are thIs very,
very,
a contorted beIng,
a which is,
which is capable of incredible greatness
and beauty and kindness and forgiveness
and also capable of they're opposites.
And that's,
and that it's not,
it's not that you are one and other
people are the other,
but the,
all of us,
uh,
both,
all the time and so there never is a
victory and there never is a win other
than trying to deal with and restrain
your own worst impulses in the life that
you have
and honestly express all the issues that
arrive while you're trying to do,
do that.
Absolutely.
And,
and,
and trying to tell the truth where you
see it and,
and giving voice to it and trying to.
I mean,
you know,
this is just,
it just seems so clear to me that,
that if people,
if people could realize this is a
central problem of the thing that you
and I and others,
all faith is the desire to claim that,
that somebody who disagrees on issue
isn't just have a disagreeing mind but
evil and that in any way we have in
britain,
we are ranked at the moment still by 18
months after a single vote on a single
matter of governance.
We are still wracked by really
unpleasant polItics from brexit.
Yeah.
And I suspect it's not an,
I hate the overlap of the two,
but it's probably something like the
trump events here,
but again and again,
you come back to the same thing,
which is just instead of thinking one
side is entirely right and the other
entirely,
it didn't say you give up on objective
factor anything else,
but just consider that your opponent
might be approaching us with an honest
motive and might have honest reasons for
disagreeing with you.
And in the absence of that and with
media just endlessly feeding us whatever
it is we know our own side happens to
think I'm in the absence of that.
I just see our trenches in both our
countries just being dug deeper and
deeper until,
until there's just no hope of being able
to even shout over the top and be heard.
And one can get to that stage if,
if,
as I say,
you recognize that it's,
it's,
it's not a constant fight against nazis.
And you know,
I mean it,
it,
it's.
By the way,
I'd also never to forget that the nazis
didn't seem like the nazi's were a lot
of people when the nazis were being
nazis.
Um,
uh,
but it's just,
it's just not as easy as that.
No,
it's not in a,
but it's,
it's an easy way to demonize the other
side.
Yeah,
it's an easy way to prop up your side.
It's a,
it's a cheap trick.
It is.
But going back to where we started,
what if the cheap trick ends up having
some terrible consequence,
um,
of making all of our defenses go down.
Um,
you know,
if,
uh,
if I'm not
well,
the both of you,
I mean,
when we started the conversation off
with that community guideline strike
like,
good lord,
this is,
this really is a very,
very strange time.
Very strange.
Always was.
Douglas.
Thank you very much.
I really,
really enjoyed this conversation.
I really appreciate it.
And your book that is out now is death
of europe.
It's immigration,
identity
islam,
and uh,
it's variable.
If you can find any bookshops left,
you got to get it online.
You can get it online as well.
There's a few barnes and nobles out
there.
All right.
Thank you,
Douglas Murray,
ladies and gentlemen.
Great.
Pleasure.
Thank you.
My pleasure.